-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now if you don't mind,
we are going to get to the news.
Today was Groundhog Day,
and Punxsutawney Phil
says we've got about six
or seven winters left.
[ Laughter ]
Senate Judiciary chairman
Dick Durbin
told reporters this week
that White House chief of staff
Ron Klain leaked the news
of Supreme Court justice
Stephen Breyer's retirement
and -- this is crazy --
Rihanna's pregnancy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, congratulations, my friend.
House majority whip Jim Clyburn
said in a new interview
that President Biden's
yet-to-be-named
Supreme Court nominee
should be someone who did not
go to an Ivy League school,
as opposed to someone who went
but doesn't remember it.
[ Applause ]
Republican senator John Kennedy
told reporters recently
that he had concerns about
President Biden's criteria
for a Supreme Court nominee
and said, "I want a nominee
who knows a law book
from a J. Crew catalog."
I'm sorry, do you think that's
where black women famously shop?
[ Laughter ]
'Cause if so, I don't think
you know a J. Crew catalog.
That catalog is so white,
it's what they used to swear in
Amy Coney Barrett.
[ Laughter ]
Tesla has issued a recall
for more than 50,000 vehicles
to disable a feature
which prevents them
from rolling through stop signs
without coming to a full halt,
or as Tesla calls it,
Mercedes mode.
[ Laughter ]
The Washington Football Team
announced today
that it officially
changed its name
to the Washington Commanders,
as in "Rams 37, Commanders 3."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, today was singer
Shakira's 45th birthday.
Her hips still don't lie,
but they have started repeating
the same stories.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.